Identificar las intersecciones con el eje
"x" y "y" de la línea "y" igual a "3x" menos 9.
Después grafica la línea.
Así que la intersección con el eje "x",
que vamos a escribir como x-int,
es el punto donde la línea intersecta al eje "x",
que es el eje horizontal.
Así es que cuando algo intersecta el eje
"x" lo que sabemos de su... digo,
podrían ser muchas cosas... pero lo que sabemos es
que el valor "y" es 0, ok.
Significa que no nos hemos movido
en la dirección vertical, ok.
Entonces esto significa literalmente que
"y" es igual a 0, ok.
Entonces, si "y" es igual a 0 simplemente tomaríamos esta relación y resolvemos la ecuación para "x".
Ahora, con la intersección con el eje "y",
esto literalmente significa...
bueno si estamos en el eje "y", solo nos movemos hacia arriba y hacia abajo... aquí significa...
aquí significa que no nos hemos movido
en la dirección "x", ok.
Eso es lo que significa, no nos hemos movido
ni a la derecha ni a la izquierda, así que
en este caso significa que "x" es igual a 0, ok.
Ok y esto nos definirá exactamente en que
punto se ha intersectado, ok.
Utilizando la relación inicial.
Ok, vámonos con la primera, ok.
Entonces si "y" es igual a 0, resolvemos para
"x" y tenemos que 0 es igual a "3x" menos 9,
sumamos 9 de ambos lados, ok, para... para
digamos aislar las "x"y nos queda 9 igual a "3x".
Y ahora, dividimos ambos lados por 3 y aquí se cancela y nos queda 3 es igual a "x" o que "x" es igual a 3.
Así que el punto en donde intersectamos al eje "x" es...
bueno, primero ponemos la coordenada de "x"
que es 3 y en "y" vale 0, es el 3, 0.
1, 2, 3, aquí estamos en el punto 3, 0.
Ok.
Ésta es la intersección con el eje "x".
Y notemos que éste, como habíamos dicho
está en el eje "x" y tiene un valor de "y"
igual a 0, porque no nos hemos movido ni hacia
arriba ni hacia abajo, correcto,
solo estamos recapitulando un poco.
Ahora, para la intersección con el eje "y",
simplemente vamos a sustituir en esta expresión
"x" igual a 0, entonces "y" es igual a 3...
déjenme elegir el color rosa...
así que "y" es igual a 3 por "x" que es 0
menos 9,
que esto simplemente se hace 0 y 0 menos 9 es -9.
Así que tenemos el punto 0, -9.
Cuando "x" es igual a 0, vamos abajo 9 unidades,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 y uno más, 9, ok,
aquí está nuestro punto, el 0, -9.
Y este por supuesto se queda en el eje "y".
Ahora, no nos hemos movido a la derecha ni
a la izquierda, eso es lo que hay que tomar
en cuenta y que por eso estamos
en la línea del eje "y", ok.
Entonces para definir la línea, necesitamos
conectar estos puntos puntos,
que se va a ver algo... ok,
no tengo una herramienta de línea pero bueno,
espero dibujarlo de la mejor forma, es la línea que conecta estos dos puntos, sigue creciendo,
esto en forma de línea recta, ok, así y así se sigue.
Ok...
esto se mantiene más o menos así...
y se sigue en esta dirección, verdad...
Entonces digo, yo sé que mi línea no es
de lo más derechita pero bueno,
se entiende la idea.
Y ya hemos acabado.